♪ ♪
>> Tucker: DISGRACED LAWYER
HAS A BOOK OUT AND HE PROBABLY
HASN’T EVEN READ.
ATTACKING DONALD TRUMP.
HAVE YOU READ IT?
NO ONE WILL ASK HIM THAT OF
COURSE, IN FORMATION TO PROMOTE
IT.
CNN IS LEADING THE CHARGE.
TOMORROW NIGHT, MICHAEL COHEN
WITH MUCH HIGH CRIME INTERVIEW
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW MANY
TOUGH QUESTIONS ON THE SCENE AND
PROBABLY NOT TOO MANY.
AND MICHAEL COHEN WITH A SECOND
HOME WITH A LOT OF CLOSE FRIENDS
OVER THERE INCLUDING THIS LAST
WEEK, THE CHIEF BODY BUILDING
CORRESPONDENT CHRIS CUOMO AND
MUCH MORE ON THE FRIENDSHIP
BETWEEN MICHAEL COHEN AND CUOMO
LATER IN THE WEEK.
BUT, ALSO, THEY ONCE HAD KIDS AT
A PRIVATE SCHOOL IN NEW YORK.
MICHAEL COHEN SERVED ON THE
BOARD WITH HIS EX-WIFE.
THEY HAVE LONG BEEN PERSONAL
FRIENDS OF THE NARCISSIST WITH
THE CAPACITY PERSON ATOMIC FOR
PERSONAL FRIENDSHIP.
THE RELATIONSHIP TELLS YOU A LOT
ABOUT HOW THINGS ACTUALLY WORK
IN MEDIA AND IN POLITICS.
CASE IN POINT, MARCH 10, 2016,
THAT WOULD BE THE DAY OF THE
FINAL REPUBLICAN PRIMARY DEBATE,
V3 CALL JEFF ZUCKER ON HIS
CELL PHONE.
AND CNN HOSTING THE DEBATE IN
MIAMI AND WORKING FOR
DONALD TRUMP AT THE TIME HE
WANTED TO CHECK IN ABOUT IT.
JEFF ZUCKER STARTED BRAGGING AS
HE IS TO DO COME A FEW WORDS
ABOUT THEIR FAMILY AND LAUNCHED
INTO A LECTURE ABOUT HIS OWN
IMPORTANCE.
HERE IS THE THING, SUCKER
ANNOUNCED TO MICHAEL COHEN YOU
CANNOT BE ELECTED PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES WITHOUT CNN.
FOX AND MSNBC CAREER RELEVANT IN
A GENERAL ELECTION CANDIDATE.
IF YOU WANT TO RUN THE COUNTRY
IN OTHER WORDS, JEFF ZUCKER SAID
YOU HAVE TO SNIFF.
IT IS NOT THAT CNN NEEDS THE
HELP, WE ARE KILLING IT AND
DOING GREAT, BUT DONALD TRUMP
BADLY NEEDS CNN.
"YOU HAVE GREAT GOATS, GREAT
UNDERSTANDING OF THE THEORY
DOMINIC EVERYTHING BUT MISSING
THE VOTE ON HOW IT WORKS GOING
FORWARD.
OH, HOW IT WORKS GOING FORWARD.
OKAY MICHAEL COHEN REPLIES, WHY
DON’T YOU EMAIL DONALD TRUMP AND
TELLS HIM THAT AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN THE CONVERSATION COMMIT
JEFF ZUCKER PAUSES.
IT TURNS OUT THAT JEFF ZUCKER,
HE SAID.
>> IS YOUR LAWYER, AS YOU
UNDERSTAND AND AS FOND AS I AM
OF THE BOSS, HE ALSO HAS A
TENDENCY COMETH YOU KNOW, IF I
CALL HIM OR EMAIL HIM, HE IS
CAPABLE OF GOING OUT IN THIS
NEXT RALLY AND SING WE JUST
TALKED.
AND I CAN’T HAVE THAT, IF YOU
KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE WOULD KNOW I
TALKED TO TRUMP AND I CAN’T HAVE
THAT, IF YOU KNOW WHAT I’M
SAYING.
WE KNOW WHAT YOU ARE SAYING JEFF
ZUCKER.
YOU ARE SAYING SECRETLY AND YOU
ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO PLAY ALL
SIDES.
YOU CAN BRAG ABOUT HOW POWERFUL
YOU ARE, THE BIG TIME NETWORK
HONCHO KINGMAKER, THE MAN WHO
DECIDES HE’S PRESIDENT.
LIKE ALL TINY INSECURE PEOPLE
YOU MIX FLATTERY WITH SWAGGER
AND REFER TO DONALD TRUMP AS
"THE BOSS" EVEN WHEN HE IS NOT
ON THE CALL.
YOU ARE HAPPY TO DO THAT BUT YOU
DON’T WANT ANYONE IN YOUR
TINY -- DOING THAT.
WHAT WOULD DON LEMON THINK IF
YOU WERE TALKING TO SATAN?
HE MIGHT THROW YOU OFF THE SET.
AND THE WORLD CAN CONCLUDE YOU
ARE A DENNIS PHONY AND FOR GOOD
REASON.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP IT HIDDEN,
SORRY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I’M SAYING.
BUT HE ASSURED MICHAEL COHEN
THIS IS NOT PERSONAL.
IT’S NOT THAT I DON’T WANT TO
TALK TO TRUMP EVERY DAY.
I HAVE TO BE CAREFUL BECAUSE
I’VE GOT TO BE CAREFUL.
I JUST DON’T WANT HIM TALKING
ABOUT IT ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT COME I WILL
GIVE HIM A CALL RIGHT NOW ANDISH
WHO AM LUCKY IN THE DEBATE
TONIGHT.
>> I HAVE BOTH THESE PROPOSALS
FOR HIM.
I WANT TO DO A WEEKLY SHOW.
IS HE BACK IN NEW YORK TOMORROW,
DO YOU KNOW?
>> Tucker: WAIT, WHAT?
A WEEKLY SHOW ON CNN COMMIT JEFF
ZUCKER ON CNN WANTED TO GIVE A
WEEKLY SHOW TO A MAN HE DENOUNCE
AS A RACIST?
OF COURSE, HE NEVER DID GET THE
SHOW AND ANDERSON COOPER IS
STILL THERE.
BUT JEFF ZUCKER TOOK THE TIME TO
DISPENSE QUITE A BIT OF
UNSOLICITED POLITICAL ADVICE TO
MICHAEL: "I THINK THE OTHER GUYS
WILL GANG UP ON HIM
TREMENDOUSLY TONIGHT, JEFF
ZUCKER SAID ABOUT THE DEBATE
TONIGHT, AND HE WAS WORRIED
ABOUT A TEXT FROM THE OTHER
REPUBLICANS ON THE STAGE.
BUT JEFF ZUCKER SAID THAT TRUMP
WOULD PREVAIL AND THEN JEFF
ZUCKER OFFERED THIS FROM A
SURPRISINGLY DETAILED POLITICAL
ADVICE.
LISTEN.
>> HOW MANY TIMES DO YOU THINK
THAT THEY WILL CALL HIM TONIGHT?
>> A LOT.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU SHOULD DO,
JUST CALL ALL DAY.
YOU GET SO USED TO IT SO THAT
WHEN HE HEARS IT FROM RUBIO, IT
DOESN’T MATTER.
HEY, CON MAN, CON MAN, MAN,
CON MAN, CON MAN.
AND SO, YOU KNOW HE THINKS THAT
IS HIS NAME, YOU KNOW?
>> Tucker: HAY CON MAN, HEY
CON MAN, HEY CON MAN, SAYS
THE CON MAN.
THEY WERE IT IS, THAT IS HOW IT
REALLY WORKS.
INSIDE TIPS HOW TO NAVIGATE THE
CNN DEBATE FROM THE HEAD OF CNN
COMMIT JEFF ZUCKER A MAN WHO
SUPPOSEDLY A JOURNALIST SECRETLY
WORKING AS A POLITICAL
CONSULTANT.
THE GUY THAT RUNS THE DEMOCRATIC
FAITHFUL NEWS WORK GIVING
POLITICAL ADVICE TO THE
REPUBLICAN FRONT RUNNER.
DONALD TRUMP’S CHIEF TORMENTOR
COLLUDING SECRETLY WITH
DONALD TRUMP’S LAWYER.
IT IS ALL BEWILDERING.
BUT THAT IS WHAT IT IS REALLY
LIKE.
THAT IS THE REAL JEFF ZUCKER.
A MAN WHO BELIEVES IN NOTHING.
A MAN WHOSE ONLY GOAL IS
PROXIMITY TO POWER NO MATTER WHO
WIELDS IT.
NO WONDER HE IS FRIENDS WITH
MICHAEL COHEN.
A LOT MORE TOMORROW, INCLUDING
WHAT WE WILL EXPLAIN.
HOW ABOUT CNN INTERVIEWS AND HOW
DID THEY COME ABOUT?
SOME OF THEM SEEM COACHED.
THE GUEST KNOWS WHAT THE HOST
WILL ASK.
IT TURNS OUT, BECAUSE THAT IS
REALLY WHAT HAPPENS.
THEY ARE COACHED.
WE WILL PROVE IT TOMORROW NIGHT.
HERE IS A SAMPLE.
>> I THINK THE WAY THIS
CONVERSATION GOES IS ALMOST
EXACTLY THE ONE WE ARE HAVING.